I'm archaeologist Andrew kinkela and I'm
here to answer some of your questions on
Twitter this is archeology support
[Music]
at Landy hoes what is the difference
between archeology and paleontology
paleontology is about very old things
like dinosaurs and on the order of
millions of years old archeology is
about much more recent human past
largely the last 10 000 years there is a
wing of archeology that deals with
ancient human ancestors where we're
studying on the order of early human
evolution from several million years ago
at any XD asks what do you think is the
most significant archaeological
Discovery in recent years and why the
find of Richard III which was amazing in
a parking lot that just shows you that
things change people move around people
forget things that were once really
really important another one on my top
ten the find of the Shipwreck the
endurance off the coast of Antarctica
the endurance got lodged in the ice
ultimately sank because the ice would
melt and the ship would sink they had to
use uh rovs remote operated vehicles in
order to find this thing because of its
depth at Athen and fanaco one asks y'all
only use those little brushes at dig
sites like that would drive me mad using
that all day we use all different kinds
of tools in archeology depending on the
situation at hand the trial is the tool
of the archaeologist you can dig fast
with the long edge of it or you can be
really precise with the pointy tip
archeology is much more about touch
sometimes than you would think and sound
you could hear
a little clink time to slow down so I
take the trial put it down bust out the
brush as I brush we can see the artifact
at that point we can switch to the
popsicle stick I can push and you don't
have that metallic clink what we would
do at this point pedestal the artifact
we would dig around it we can say the
artifact is 10 centimeters deep 20
centimeters from the West Wall 17
centimeters from the north wall and then
we have the artifacts exact location
this artifact is called a Clovis point a
very specific tool to some of the first
people to ever enter the new world at
Chun Matthias asks honestly I still
don't know how the Rosetta Stone Works
the Rosetta Stone is one of the most
important archaeological discoveries
because it led to the cracking of
Egyptian hieroglyphics Rosetta Stone was
found in 1799 by Napoleon's science team
that he brought with him in the town of
Rosetta in Egypt what makes it so
important is be because it says the same
thing three times at the top it's in
ancient Egyptian hieroglyphics in the
middle it's in demotic and at the bottom
it's in Greek so you have this one piece
that you can read and then you sort of
have a key where you can start to build
off of and figure out what the different
symbols mean at I am najoju asks curious
about these stone tools discovered from
ancient man how
rolled down a hill it would look
different if I'm an ancient tool maker
and I'm using a hammer Stone on this I'm
gonna hit it really hard to get a flake
to pop off is going to create what's
called a bulb of percussion it's gonna
create this divot also in terms of
ancient stone tools they're going to use
things like obsidian it's volcanic glass
those types of stones can make a really
really sharp edge on the flip side this
is a hammer Stone it was very
specifically sought after by ancient
people for its qualities of not being
too soft or too hard and you can use it
to make good stone tools at zeph Wagner
asks I don't know what the hell a dial
of Destiny is but I sure as hell know
what a dial is inherently less exciting
than an arc a temple or a Grail the dial
of Destiny is the new artifact that
they're going to use in the new Indiana
Jones movie what they're relating this
to is something called the antikythera
mechanism and its ability to track the
rotate nation of planets over time I
think what it really shows is an
excellent use of math to make the gear
so precise that it could at least work
for a while at atang by Leah asks why do
archaeologists excavate Graves again
sometimes we come across them and we
don't expect it I will say that is the
most common way that we find human
remains it's a little bit of a deep
moment you do start to think about your
own mortality human remains that you
find in a grave tell you so much about
the past the human skeleton itself can
tell you how that person died did they
have any diseases what was their social
status it can tell you about the
religion of the culture when we excavate
something like a human burial we go very
slow we work with local communities
where you're going to store these human
remains are you going to re-berry these
human remains at goth Logan asks
carbon dating thing work carbon 14 is an
isotope it breaks down over time and
what we can do is measure the rate at
which it breaks down let's say after I'm
filming this I walk off and I die in the
parking lot my carbon 14 starts to go
down
5730 years from today I will have half
as much carbon 14 as I did in the
beginning now if you add another 5730
years I have a quarter of what I had now
you got to watch it because it only
works on things that were once alive you
cannot carbon 14 date a rock but for
living things burials remains we can get
a date for it at our Stevens asks lidar
is being Advanced partly by its use in
self-driving car research how long has
it been used for archeology it's been
used in archeology in the last 10 years
or maybe more but lidar is a bunch of
lasers shot down from a plane or a helic
copter that flies over a site what it
gets is really really specific
Geographic and mapping data so as the
plane flies over and shoots a bunch of
lasers the trees actually blow a little
so a couple of the laser beams will get
down to the ground surface it used to be
just prohibitively expensive these days
the more and more we get of that the
more projects actually have it due to
the decreasing cost at Bryce P Wright
asks how often do archaeologists have to
think are these bones a crime scene or a
discovery I did once work on a salvage
archeology project where a construction
crew had accidentally hit a family plot
that was about 80 years old the skeletal
material was still kind of supple you
can really tell the difference if you're
working with something that's thousands
of years old because it's totally dry
and it started to kind of Wither away so
they're not bleach white like you would
think they're sort of a dull Brown I
still will call the coroner just to make
double sugar at Katya zizing asks anyone
else wonder how accurate a forensic
facial reconstruction artist would be if
they just had your skull to work off of
we have to realize that it's not perfect
in terms of facial reconstruction from a
skull some things you can get are stuff
like the cheeks or the cheeks higher or
lower the eye sockets the brow Ridge the
chin the teeth sometimes uh the the
channel being more of a jutting chin but
stuff like what was the overall shape of
the nose you know the ears you're gonna
go with the trends of the time so if
you're working on a skull that's 4 000
years old and it's a male skull you're
gonna put some sort of beard on it
because they didn't have Bic Razors four
thousand years ago archeology is
literally three pieces of the Thousand
piece puzzle at Malachi Waters asks do
archaeologists just go to random places
and be like I feel like there's
something important here and then just
start digging we only excavate after
we've surveyed and mapped the location
we are looking for the best possible
places that archaeological sites might
exist the ancient Maya would build on
good soil if there's a forestry company
or something who has made a map of the
soil quality throughout the region I
love getting that map because that makes
my work that much easier I was working
on a project in downtown L.A where they
were replacing the sidewalk and they
took up some of the concrete and there
was a human skeleton right there this
was a human skeleton that had been there
for hundreds of years in the modern
world we want to have archaeologists
along with construction projects and
building projects because they do find
things like this from time to time at
John engineer asks what's the most
valuable artifact you have ever found
I'm gonna go with an entire Mayan
pyramid I found the pyramid through
Google Earth at home I rolled the cursor
over this area of the jungle and the
altimeter would go blue blue blue and I
thought you know next time I'm in that
area of the Jungle I gotta go back there
and check out that area and yes it
actually was an ancient Maya pyramid at
Joe six Totoro bear asks what
archaeological find do you wish you had
made and why the tomb of Tutankhamun
Howard Carter in the early 1920s it took
him several field seasons and he had to
look for months through the entire
Valley of the Kings at his last little
survey Square that's where it was those
artifacts are amazing stuff like wood
that's 3 000 years old it looks like it
was made last week they tell you so much
about this little moment in time when
this young king died unexpectedly at
Jane loves bees asks do archaeologists
even do sex estimations of skeletons yes
and it's usually fairly easy the two
best places to look are the skull and
the pelvis for a male skull it tends to
be more robust it'll just sort of be
bigger overall a bit more angular
although there's a lot of overlap on
this so you have to look at different
very specific parts of the skull in
order to be sure I got this wrong once
now it was a skeleton that had no head
the pelvis looked very very narrow and I
was like it's a guy once they got it to
the lab and they could look more closely
it was a female who had a very narrow
pelvis in the field there's still parts
of it covered with mud it's in a bad
position but once it's in the lab it's
under controlled conditions you can get
really exact measurements you can just
get a much better idea of what's going
on at reactive Yuri asks I finished
watching ancient apocalypse last night
why do the experts dismiss Hancock's
hypothesis as baseless ancient
apocalypse is a Netflix series whose
Central premise is there was a cataclysm
about 10 000 years ago that destroyed a
super Advanced super civilization and we
only have bits and pieces of that left
it didn't happen there is no evidence
one of the best examples of this is the
piriris map it was done in the early
1500s made by this guy named Perry
Reeves pseudo-archaeologists like Graham
Hancock say this is evidence that
ancient people explored Antarctica it's
just not it's proof that ancient map
makers ran out of paper curved it around
this is just a part of South America we
can't use this today as serious
scientific evidence it's not at motmot
org asks did you know that the Maya
believed that natural sinkholes called
cenotes were sacred portals to the
underworld I am a mayonist and I did my
dissertation on the cenotes of Belize
sometimes they were just used for water
but other times they did sacrifice
people into the cenotes from time to
time I don't want you guys to think that
human sacrifice happened like every
weekend or something it didn't if the
crops were going poorly and if there was
no rain you may sacrifice somebody who
was usually a captured Warrior from one
of the other cities take this person to
the edge of the Cenote you would slash
them through their chest we have found
human remains and some of the cenotes we
have accounts from the Spanish of seeing
this kind of thing happen in terms of my
research we did find a little building
right on the edge of the Cenote and we
would call that a water Shrine and that
would be the place where these kind of
rituals would take place at Ethan's room
asks why do archaeologists dress like
that it depends on the environment
you're working in for me in the jungle
I'm gonna wear a light shirt I'm gonna
have boots on I'm gonna bring a machete
with me in order to cut through the
jungle I'm gonna wear a hat protects you
from the Sun you will also bring with
you a bunch of different tools and in a
backpack or a satchel a GPS unit if I
had to bring one thing with me it would
be a compass the compass will get you
home GPS units are great they work on
batteries and once you're out of
batteries you're dead always trust your
compass at Rocketeer 46 asks why are
there so many archaeological discoveries
of late are there more archaeologists or
is it technology or what's the reason it
is true that we tend to be finding more
and more stuff we do have more modern
technology like lidar there's also
satellite technology that help us find
new sites and we can see things like
ancient trade routes but a major part of
this is World overpopulation there is
more and more excavation so we find new
archaeological sites in every country of
the world at Boyka D20 asks what do
archaeologists not know or debate that
you would most like an answer to when
did human beings first enter North and
South America the overwhelming evidence
points to Asia across to Alaska and then
down we have very good evidence up to
about 16 or 17 000 years ago it's really
hard to say after that you have sites
way down in South America that can be
quite old too 21 000 years or 40 000
years but the evidence isn't quite good
enough a decade from now maybe we know
more than we do now those are all the
questions for today thanks for watching
archeology support
[Music]